it was popping GQ this is Anderson pack
and these are my essentials 10
essentials yes Laura the first century
la people think these are just foreplay
you know it's not just for looks I would
do anything just for some 20/20 vision
I like glasses too but just let the wake
up and just be able to see this gorgeous
thing in the mirror sometimes I play
drums so I break a lot of glasses with
the drum state there's lyrica is a cool
part can't see you with this pitch black
Gucci frames on let me take the take
them up and we get the full of skull so
that's like good part to like take my
glasses off usually the girls like me
like kills eye cream shut off my artist
31 and up taking care of yourselves in
the morning hungover no back to 21 you
know saying put it on your eyes put it
anywhere where you got wrinkles the
balls anything next essential there's a
gold chain I believe it's Indian gold
Thundercat gave me this he was drunk and
screaming had a dinner party that we
were invited to and he came in and he
ruined the party but he gave me this I
told him when you sober up I'm not
giving you this back he said mommy I
love you
where does change don't be afraid Andy
so I wear it every day it's like he's
really special to me is like one of my
heroes he's never getting it back
Cologne I've been rocking with the
Hermes voyage this is a nice one
okay you got to do it like this shoes
not on the clothes cake on the actual
skin they can't just rest on your
clothes as like you know then it just
gotta smell like weed and mixture of
stuff but if you put it on your actual
skin and you slide it out and go smell
like you most sweat Hermes you know my
baby loves got a man everybody that
knows me
you know I'm pulling up with this the
party is an automatic turn
any situation to a complete turn up pipe
up session you have fully charged two
USBs in the back best is when you go on
the plane
start playing some super ignorant the
most ignorant thing you could play an
elevator on a commercial flight yeah
and that nobody knows where it's coming
from you put it in the thing in the bag
and you just just playing some Kodak
black right now I got a bunch of [ __ ] on
my purse but mostly like 92,000 Zehra
stuff listening in the same [ __ ] you
know the best shape I got my newest
senpai was his birthday
he's 1 years of kissing pictures of the
family you know I'm a little son you
know he's 7 got wifey you know aim
that's an essential keeping the family
close as I come around a lot of stuff
that's like it seems like an important
for at the time but what matters man a
wallet you know saying oh my you know
spend a little money on accessories you
know while it's I'll splurge Gucci I
might not have the full like Gucci
romper but I got the wallet and you know
working my way up with all no cash is
king
so got to keep some of that on you don't
just be depending on the cards because
the bank will show [ __ ] down
I sent you water I saw the little video
so if this gets the best pH balance I
don't really even know what it does but
I always got to have just matte water
with no one to drink as much as we do
party as much as we do
you gotta drink as much water especially
this is actually a sin this is essential
and I'm gonna need lunch but if I have
some water
essential
another thing goes hand-in-hand with the
water is a throat coat oh my god a
singer his artist guys know what's up
with this
sometimes my vocals sound like a pack of
Newports and this thing will have me
sounding like [ __ ] I don't even know
Taylor Swift I've got the beanie you
know sometimes we gotta like switch it
up you need different outfits so I like
him a little bit extra beanie and kiss
on switch it up here and there shut up
the brick of wool they got the right
beanie so I got a big forehead about
huge it was like this is it I'm a big
bucket head it's another essential rock
oh I got it in Japan like a secondhand
store I named him Rocko after rocco
siffredi my favorite actor always got my
back my Wolf Pack keep me straight
watching my back all y'all tryin to
creep up on me he sees everything
[Music]